i'm going to ask you a marvel question
because yeah
i'm me but i i am it's like a two-parter
and it's not going to get you in trouble
uh one of the things are you liking the
show
yeah dude listen i'm i'm i'm [ __ ] all
in but i've only seen
i've only seen the first third of it
like this is like a big thing that i've
seen two episodes of
so i'm so i've only seen the first two
this
friday's episode three where i'm going
with this is
one of the things that i'm so blown away
by is kevin feige and his ability to
constantly reinvent what marvel is and
what this mcu is and i'm just curious if
you could talk about
why is kevin feige such a [ __ ]
awesome producer
and part two is um have you guys talked
about
because he kevin told me that he's
talked about doing some
season twos of certain shows have you
talked about doing a second season
of falcon and winter soldier no we have
not and i'll tell you that honestly we
have not
um uh i have i have no i
as as per usual i don't i don't quite
know what the next step
is you know like we never really do and
and
maybe some people do you know like again
maybe like i
maybe downey used to know i don't know
but like at this point in my life like
11 years into it i don't even you know i
i i got on the phone with him and you
know just to
catch up and and we were saying i was
saying to him i was like dude
you could [ __ ] tell me to go swimming
you know i don't know like
like you could i'll do anything like it
doesn't it doesn't matter
or you know or if or or if this is it
like my heart is just as big you know
like i i have nothing but complete utter
gratitude for
for the opportunities that that i've
gotten from him and especially just
also that anthony and i have gotten now
at the show you know
again my on my end to yet again reinvent
this character find new nuances about
him
so it's already kind of a win in so many
ways you know for me and
second of all you know i i was like
i i asked him i was like hey don't you
like
how do you feel like when you want to
direct one of something one day or
something and you know he was like
obviously he was like oh it's about you
know it's for it's for better people to
handle that or
you know it's for other other and i
think one of the things about him that i
feel like i've loved
always is how how modest he is you know
and how
and how unbelievably grateful like he
really is grateful when something works
it he really like it 10 years in 11
years how many years now like
it's like i feel like that child like
exuberance is always there you know you
see the flicker in his eyeballs like as
he lights up and when you're talking
about a character he loves or
hey by the way like they they really
love this like
i think he's in love with what he does
and i think
that's a big part of why you know
there's there's a there's a consistent
passion there
from from him to to to always find
interesting ways to to tell the story
but that that kind of makes
sense and and um i don't know he doesn't
get a lot of credit for that actually i
feel like i thought
one division was a really big [ __ ]
you know like like a creative tape you
know
and you know loki's gonna be its own
thing right and
again we existed our tone is very
different because of
we were in the in the tone of the movies
where and
it's a much more grounded way but again
like now we're developing this sort of
buddy comedy aspect to these guys
there there's comedy to this winter
soldier character that never was there
before and
you know i think i think it's always
just um
and and he's he's he's a people's person
he's very
um you know he's surrounded himself with
with the best and i think he and and and
his thing is always the best idea wins
you know there's no ego there man and
and you know that's
a huge huge huge thing so um
yeah maybe that i don't know yeah the
thing about kevin feige is that um
if it was easy to do what he's doing
everyone would do it
well exactly um and that's
that's probably true but i i also feel
like i
like i said i don't my impression is
that there's
nobody's over at that studio you know
getting caught in
um they just love the work you know they
don't get caught in the noise they don't
they
they're not you know they're not as com
they're just always constantly grateful
of like
which is if you look at the movies
they've sort of always done a lot of
the endings of the movies like that is
like well this could be it but maybe
we'll get lucky and we'll get another
one you know it's like there's never
been like well yeah we're gonna
yeah we'll just we're marvel we'll just
[ __ ]
hit another home run like there's always
this
thing of embracing you know
the last bill for what it is and and and
the hope of
of of a continuation without expectation
and that's
very difficult to do at that level